in a very basic sense I'd love to know
where this idea came from my
understanding is that parts of it have
been percolating in your mind for the
better part of 25 years that's - that's
only but the in terms of like the the
idea of this is a story about a couple
that cheats on their lovers with each
other that blind King you know that's
kind of one of those things that drops
out of the sky and I was counting around
for maybe the past couple years whatever
they attracted to me was this idea that
the narrative was the wholesome
narrative was in within that sentence
and it was something that it took me a
while to figure out like to find the
time and the space and also the
direction that it could potentially go
but it it would state you know I think
you gotta these ideas and then the ones
that to stay and kind of playing and you
start picturing until the time you're
ready to write that was one of those and
then in terms of how why then I'm I
think I went through a situation once I
get got to my 40s where suddenly I gone
through the waves of you know births and
death and suddenly I was surrounded by
people that were splitting up and there
are couples that I knew and I love them
as couples and I was it was hard for me
to kind of just come to peace with the
idea that this there's love that I
believed in of them just being gone and
so in some ways this was also a way to
make peace with that so when you're kind
of coming up with your wishlist of who
you would want in these to lead roles we
were talking backstage I said how long
has it been since Debra wingers had a
lead role in a film and you said over 20
years we went back on IMDB forget Paris
is like 1995 how did you even have the
guts to approach her and did you just
think you would have a shot at getting
her to do this movie I had it I had an
amazing experience where I made a film
called Terry in 2011 I was doing a
screening of it in New York City and the
QA and on the way out
this woman stops me and
it's Debra Winger and she's there with
her son and she stops me it's a brief
conversation which she just expressed
how much that the film really resonated
with her and obviously it meant a lot to
me because it was coming from Debra but
also there was a moment in that
conversation where I just feeling those
eyes that I knew so well from films
feeling those eyes on me and feeling
what that impact was it stayed with me
in a big way and I remember walking away
feeling like there's something there
there's something said there that wasn't
in the words but there was something
there was a connection that I felt with
her and then about a month or two later
I wound up receiving a handwritten
letter from that said Debra Winger on
the stationery and just again expressing
how much she cared for the film and for
me to keep her in mind for something
like maybe we can make something
together so which I took the letter put
it right above my desk and I really
brought her every project that I was
involved when even the the show I was
doing with HBO like I and to her credit
she would just say I don't think that's
there this is not it um so I wrote with
her in mind but also not with a
guarantee she proved herself to be
extremely as selective as we all know
she can be but then dia when I wrote it
- I wrote it with her in mind and I when
I got it turned she was the first she
said yes and you know that really
dictated the type of movie it was going
to be it's it was fun for me just
sitting here watching the credits roll
because your cast your entire cast is
like 11 people and then it gets to the
point where it's lists every member's
name of the orchestra and it's like 50
or 60 people and Mandy Hoffman who did
your score it's such a such a
fascinating score because in many ways
it feels at odds
it was the flowery nature of it this
romantic nature of it at odds with what
we're seeing on screen but in a really
cool way how did you and Mandy come up
with how the two would interact well let
me first just say this is the first of
that Orchestra told us that they've been
credited individually and I think it is
50 people and
while it's funny to have so many more
people on that said it was really
important to us after we saw what they
did I wanted to see adults the recording
and just see these individuals that we
acknowledge each of them as individuals
rather than just having Mandy and I have
again we've been working together since
about for 14 years and we we've
constantly our base has been very
minimal piano-based scores and I think
that we're both a looking to kind of go
some other direction and I think that
because the piano we had a conversation
obviously about the influences there was
that but also just because the piano is
such a main character in this story we
knew all right we're going to take that
away from everything else and that
really suddenly opened up just once that
that foundation was gone then we're
talking about strings and we're talking
about this and we're going back to the
influences and we're jumping out it was
some of those classic movies and we're
seeing this kind of schism that's
happening of where they contrast each
other and how they sync up in strange
ways I like the idea of the score of
like I've always thought of this film
beginning the way that a lot of those
romantic comedies end and that this
happens the next day or 10 years later
20 years later but what happened if this
score from those movies kept playing as
we become just do the grime of life and
and the idea that the things that you're
you know that you're escaping from
become more weight than or your first
running from if there's one thing that I
just really appreciate about this movie
is that it's a love story starring two
people who are in their 50s or I don't
know what the exact age of the
characters is is that because it's
something you felt like you haven't seen
is it something you think there ought to
be more of I did well I've been really
happy to hear that from people that they
feel like this is reflecting I do know
that that was reflecting something that
they feel but they don't get to see on
screen and I know that that was a big
pull for Tracy Tracy just felt like I
remember on the first call he just said
this idea that all these things stop
that you figure things out that suddenly
you you you're set in your ways at 50 or
around that age is just so not true for
him and not true for anybody that he
knows but also has not been true for me
for in terms of like I've never felt and
now that I'm 44 I've never felt that I'm
sad or that things have changed that
much from being 10 or 15 in a lot of in
a lot of ways so the age thing wasn't it
wasn't like a it really kind of came
down with just like I knew I wanted to
make this with Deborah if she said yes
that would dictate the kind of what the
world was and it was a world that I am
happy now that is reflected and that
people feel like it's reflecting
something well thank you for making it
and thank you for being here